We have had lots and lots of requests to make videos about Thor.
Rim people get really excited about Thor rim.
We delayed making the video until we had the sample of Thorim
and our friend max Whitby,
who makes nice samples of elements has told us on many
occasions that Thorim is the hardest element to get hold of.
Well,
one of the problems with sorghum is simply obtaining it and there are now very,
very few places in the world where you can buy any, um,
even laboratory suppliers don't sell it.
Finally, just before Christmas,
he gave us a sample and here is the sample.
This is a sample of two bits of Thorim
wire. Now you can see the first problem with Thorim is the
radioactive, so you can't post it.
I've no idea how the sample got to London.
It was brought to me in London in Max's bag,
and I brought it to Nottingham in my pocket.
Now there's no danger bringing it in my pocket because it's got a very thick
piece of plastic and 3m gives out relatively
weak radioactivity. So there is no radioactivity outside.
This Thorim as an element is not very widely
used.
It used to be used for the elements in
gas fires to get to good fire.
You have some sort of ceramic element which gets hot and radiates the heat
because flames don't radiate heat very much.
And Thorim oxide is very stable.
So people use ceramics based on thorium oxide.
But the reason that people get excited about Thorim is because of nuclear
reactors, nuclear reactors,
the two most widely used in the world of based on uranium.
You remember that different radioactive elements can have circled
isotopes. These are chemically identical atoms,
but which have different numbers of neutrons. And the uranium isotope,
which is used in nuclear reactors is uranium two, three, five,
which when it is hit by neutrons can split giving out more
neutrons and you get to chain reaction in a nuclear reactor.
You want the reaction to go nice and slowly to keep the thing hot.
So you can turn water into steam and generate a.
She says to us,
we obtain a constantly increasing number of fissions called a chain
reaction.
If you're building an atom bomb, a nuclear weapon,
you want all your uranium to go bang at the same moment.
[Inaudible].
With current nuclear technology is first all that potentially.
There's a shortage of uranium. It's a very rare element,
equally important.
You can use the uranium in the reactor,
the uranium two, three eight, which is the isotope that doesn't take pots in.
The reaction can be used to absorb neutrons and make plutonium,
which can then be used for nuclear weapons.
So if you build a reactor somewhere,
there is a danger that the waste product from that reactor or
some of the waste products could be used for making nuclear bombs.
The items of the metals,
uranium and plutonium can be most readily pressuring them to cause
nuclear explosion.
And everybody in the world generally agrees that we have to try and reduce the
number of bombs rather than making it easier for people to make more bonds
[inaudible] can be used for a completely different approach to nuclear
reactors, but which still involves uranium.
The most abundant isotope of Thorim is still rim two, three,
two. If this isotope absorbs a neutron,
it becomes Storium two, three, three is maskers up in one.
Then sequentially two of the neutrons split into
the proton and electron.
And so it goes jumps from Thor rim to protect tenure to
uranium. So you generate uranium two, three, three,
uranium two, three,
three is a very rare isotope of uranium,
but you can breed it from the Thorim,
which you've got to lots of and the uranium two, three,
three can then do your nuclear reaction break apart,
give you energy just like the other uranium isotopes.
But the difference is the T can't produce plutonium and
therefore it cannot be used to make bombs. Of course you can say, well,
if it splits in the nuclear reactor,
why can't you make a bomb out of uranium? Two, three, three?
And the answer is in principle, you could,
but as a byproduct of all the nuclear processes,
you'll also get uranium to three, two,
and uranium to three.
Two is a showstopper it's absorbs neutrons and stops
uranium exploding like a bomb. So it's safe in that way.
The other advantage of Thorim is that it's more abundant in the earth.
And because Thorim two, three,
two is the principle isotope compared to
uranium two, three, five, which is only a small amount.
There is an awful lot more 3m that could be used in reactors in the
world than there is uranium.
Except you use a nuclear reactor to produce phenomenal of heat.
The disadvantage is that you need to have some
neutrons to get things started.
You have to have a nuclear reaction to produce neutrons so that
your thrill room will turn into uranium.
But that also can be quite an advantage because for example,
you can put waste plutonium mixed with Ethereum and you
burn up the plutonium and you get more fuel sort of breeding
reactor, the stability of thorium oxide.
The one that was exploited years ago in gas fires is both an
advantage and a disadvantage.
It's an advantage because your fuel is very stable.
The downside with Storium dioxide being so stable is that you have to heat it to
a very high temperature to process it.
And that's not easy.
Relatively little work has been done on Thorim reactors compared
to the now 70 years or more nearly eight years of
research that had been done on uranium,
plutonium reactors, and therefore the engineering,
the safety and so on is not developed to the same level and the costs
of building full-size Thorim reactors would be very considerable.
It sounds like if all things being equal and we could start again,
you would advocate going down the Storium route and we're,
we're only doing uranium plutonium route because we've been doing it for so
long.
Well, you have to remember that uranium
plutonium route started because of the Manhattan
project, the atomic bomb project.
I suspect that if nuclear power had been just
started for civilian use,
that the cost would have been prohibitive and people might never have used
nuclear power.
So it is built on the legacy of
the weapons programs in many of the major countries in the world.
We now have the situation where we understand how to handle
radioactive compounds.
We don't understand entirely how to deal with the waste in practical
terms that we do in principle.
So it would be much more feasible now to go on the Thor REM cycle
than it would have been in the 1940s.
If you'd like to see a bit more footage from this interview,
check out the links on the screen or the video description.
I'll also include links to more videos about uranium radioactive elements and
our trip to the nuclear facility at Sellafield censored,
Uranian, Darkside, pallets, suitable for irradiation and nuclear factors.
And if you'd like to support periodic videos, sponsor an element,
or just help us out, you can check out our Patrion page.
That's patrion.com/periodic videos.
Sure.
Hand of science brings power unlimited
from the magic of the atom.